we've been wondering what is trump
thinking right now
is he thinking is trump so delusional
that he really thinks he can steal the
election from joe biden
there's a new report from nbc's peter
alexander which is that
trump knows he can't win he's putting on
a show peter alexander tweeting
yesterday morning quote trump
is very aware there is not a path to
victory but he believes the 72 million
who voted for him deserve a fight
so he's battling as a form of theater
for them a top
white house aide tells me so i i believe
this
understand the multi-level scam that
this is first of all trump has
republicans running all over the country
claiming they have a shot
rudy's in philadelphia eric trump's in
who the hell knows where
he's got secretary of state mike pompeo
saying we're going to have a second
trump
uh administration press secretary kelly
mckenney saying
you know every this is all it's all
fraud is this all an act
where everyone knows it's fake or does
trump think it's fake
but all of his sycophants believe it's
real i don't know
next uh layer of the scam trump is
raising money on this
so even if trump believes this is all
theater in terms of winning
trump is really raising real people's
money
okay for recounts and for legal
challenges
and that's the scam because the fine
print of trump's election fraud
fundraising
is that 50 of the money you give goes
not to lawsuits and recounts
fifty percent of the money you give goes
to paying off trump's campaign debt
there are many trump supporters many on
fixed incomes many with low
incomes who really can't afford to be
giving trump money
and this is not nanny state stuff where
i think someone should protect them
the president is scamming them it's just
the president shouldn't be scamming them
that's it it's not about regulation
if trump knows he can't win and he
realizes that this is theater
he's raising millions of dollars from
people who potentially can't afford to
be donating to trump
who were donating because they think it
might help him win
and trump himself according to peter
alexander
doesn't think this is going to make a
difference he's scamming people
to pay off his campaign debt now i know
you know a fool and their money are soon
parted and all of that stuff
but there are more and more aides coming
forward now and saying there's not even
really the idea of a plan here this is a
straight-up scam
trump aides and advisors and allies have
said
there's no grand strategy here he'll
file a lawsuit he'll send a tweet
whatever
there's no strategy and according to the
washington post quote
asked about trump's ultimate plan one
senior administration official chuckled
and said you're giving everyone too much
credit right now
they're just lying to people they know
they're lying to people and they don't
care and it's not just that they're
hurting people
by taking their money they're also
hurting the united states
they're hurting our election process
they're hurting our democracy
and along the way he continues to make
the united states a laughing stock and
he is very
clearly i mean it's a commitment at this
point donald trump is committed
to making the united states a global
laughing stock
not i i would argue not just until
january 20th when joe biden becomes
president
but probably well beyond that uh and it
is
all of our you know going back to 2015
2016
all of our worst fears about donald
trump
all of our concerns about how wacky he
might be as president how disastrous
they were understated we've talked
before about this bogus
term trump derangement syndrome used to
dismiss criticism of the president
saying oh you people are so hyperbolic
um almost no one was
hyperbolic enough about the presidency
of donald trump that's the reality
it's starting to wrap up and that's a
very good thing
a little bit later today i am going to
talk about
what can joe biden get done if he
doesn't get the senate
will trump really run again in 2024
what's next for the republican party a
lot of very important questions we will
deal with
later i'm glad you're here follow me
on twitter at dpakman and we will be
back
right after this i want to take a second
to tell you about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are very
reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over a hundred and
fifty dollars you can get there by going
to davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david